chad again delays a dialogue on national
peace the military government opposition
groups and rebels were supposed to start
discussions on a new constitution and
holding elections
so after a year of political turmoil
what will this mean for chad
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom it has been a year of
political upheaval in chat the sudden
death of long-time president idris
debbie last april left a power vacuum
his son an army general soon took over
and formed a transitional military
council muhammad idris debbie promised a
quick return to democracy but that
hasn't happened
a national dialogue with opposition
groups and rebel fighters has been
postponed for a second time the talks
were supposed to start next week about
300 representatives from the military
government opposition groups and rebel
forces have been holding preliminary
discussions in qatar but they've made
little progress on constitutional
reforms and holding elections qatar says
it hopes the delay will give all sides
more time to reach a peace agreement
so how did chad get here rebels launched
a major incursion in the north of chad
during elections last year
a day after winning the poll president
idris debbie was killed while visiting
the front lines
his son 4-star general mohammad idris
debbie rapidly took over in a coup he
promised to hold elections in 18 months
after a national dialogue
as a precondition to join those talks
rebels demanded a general amnesty and
the release of prisoners debbie complied
in march the government rebels and
opposition groups began talks in doha a
month later than scheduled
chad's stability is crucial for its
neighbors the country lies across the
sahel beside the horn of africa its
soldiers are integral to the g5 sahel
joint force battling armed groups in the
region
all right let's bring in our guests
joining us from chad's capital in jamina
is ramaji hoinathi he's a senior
researcher at the institute for security
studies
ovigue iguego is a security analyst at
the consultancy afropolitica he joins us
from abuja
and joining us from barcelona is enrique
pico she's the director of the central
africa project at the international
crisis group a very warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story ramaji let me
start with you today the dialogue on
national peace has been delayed once
again what are the reasons for that
i think that the main reason and the
official one we know from now is a
demand from the qatar
asking the chadian government to
postpone the holding of the dialogue on
the 10th of may as
planned and this demand also normally
came from a demand already
uh made by the different rebel groups
that are also sitting in dowa qatar
discussing actually with the
transitional government
and this came as a result
of the fact that the debates in dubai
are not really moving forward and uh
people sitting actually in the are far
from a peace um agreement that could
allow them a ceasefire and then coming
to the national inclusive dialogue that
is supposed to start here in the 10th of
may so here are the main reasons for
that
enrique after a year of such political
turmoil what does this delay mean for
chad
well the main consequence of the uh of
the delay uh is the impact on the
overall transition
the 18-month transition was supposed to
end
this year by the end of this year with
the celebration of
election and the
establishment of elected of new elected
authorities
so uh these uh
my rise concern about the length of the
transition about the duration of the
transition
and the legitimity of the children
authorities that
have taken power after the
dead of uh
former president like president
obigue the discussions that have been
going on thus far in qatar how have they
been going
yeah i think one of the things you have
to understand with regards to the doha
talk is that the issues are very complex
and they are very long standing because
the the problem that dealing in chat
with today is not because
you didn't just start after the death of
my president debbie even while the
former president was in office they were
they were groups who were very
dissatisfied with with the government
irregular groups opposition party
members because of how has led uh or how
he led the contract at the time so these
are very long-standing issues and it
it's a bit uh too optimistic to expect
that within 18 months you could agree or
you could even start a very solid uh
conversation and an end and end the
conversation with maybe end of a
declaration to say okay now we can move
on to national dialogue so i think one
of one of the most important things we
have to recognize is it will take a
period of time a good amount of time to
actually trash these issues one after
the other because like i said you know
it cuts across all of children's
societies what i do within you know
political reforms or is even these
questions about the state itself and
also you know uh territorial issues and
ethnic issues so it's it's quite a bit
that they have on their plate and and i
i didn't really look at the timeline i
was very pragmatic given the complexity
of the issues uh ovigue you know you
were just talking about how complicated
all these issues are and how far they go
back were you surprised uh that that the
delay happened uh that these delays have
happened or were you expecting them
honestly i was ex i was expecting them
and if you look at comments coming from
one of that one of the african diplomats
who was actually observing the talks he
is actually not not surprised as well
and and that is because yes um for
instance if we if you look the
government the government or the
traditional government in chat is very
open to to the process commits to the
process and if you if you see the when
the
front for change and conquer the child
said they wanted you know the government
to grant amnesty as a precondition for
the for the talks the government did
back back in november
amnesty to 296 you know uh combatants
from the group so there is a commitment
from the government side but if you look
at the rebuilt side the issues are that
is where it is begin to get very
complicated because you have no
demand going since like the uh
mama debbie shouldn't stand for
re-election or return of cis assets and
the government itself you know has power
to to
give made these concessions but you have
to also reconcile the competing uh
rivalries within even between the the
opposition and rebel movement because
while they might be forming a unified
position you have about 40 groups
present in in the process in doha
between the members making up this group
they are very strong divisions and are
very strong issues that divide them and
you have to reconcile all of this
because if you just move if you rush the
process what you will have is it is a
declaration like or an agreement that is
just valid on paper and then these
groups are not going to hold on to these
agreements going forward when the
national dialogue really gets underway
enrique i saw you nodding along to some
of what oviguy was saying did you want
to jump in
uh yeah no i mean uh i was um i was just
on the same line uh uh we are on the
same line on the fact that uh there is a
general consensus in uh chad on the fact
that uh the dialogue cannot be done
without the presence in germany of the
main on the leaders of the main armored
group so
there is some
tolerance in terms of delay but the
delay now they're starting to get
more and more frequent the dialogue was
supposed to be the national dialogue in
terminal was supposed to be held at the
end of the last year then in january
then has been postponed again
so uh this
uh start becoming an issue also in terms
of uh the uh also for uh for what uh it
concerned the revision of the
constitutional charter the transitional
constitution
uh this was one of the first
one of the first engagement and
condition also um
imposed by the
african union uh after the uh
the
establishment of the military
transitional authorities the fact that
those authorities cannot run for
election at the end of the transition
and the revision of the of the
constitution is one of the key points
that should be discussed during the
national dialogue in germany so all
those the issues
are still
are still
open and my
uh became
i became sensitive after almost
yeah one year after the the death of uh
president
ramanji you wrote a piece in march in
which you said the partners supporting
the country's transition dialogue and
reconciliation processes should be
firmer on the need to respect the time
frames and ensure inclusiveness so that
no stakeholder is left on the sidelines
a stalemate on these issues could see
chad slide back into political
instability so how concerned are you at
this time that instability could
continue and grow
uh yeah i'm
as the other observers i'm really uh
concerned uh by the fact that if we
don't reach any peace agreement in doha
it means that even though uh a national
dialogue is holies meaning that most of
the biggest rebel groups are out of the
deal it means that they could still uh
being able of uh rendering the country
in stable
so it's something very important coming
into a peace agreement in door but what
actually you know is kind of making the
any hope of
peace agreement failing in doha is even
the composition of the different groups
that are actually sitting at the table
the rebel groups are so fragmented as my
colleague said and so how could we come
to a peace agreement if the division is
not just
between the government and the different
groups that are speaking but also within
all the groups that are sitting to the
table
so for me
we are facing two situations actually
the first is that there is no more
visibility when
the dialogue national dialogue will
happen there is even no uh visibility on
which would be the issue the real issue
of door and then uh after that we are
then questioning you know when uh should
the the the transitional period end with
the elections and actually then uh the
initial 18 months that have been planned
are actually insufficient uh finishing
the discussions in doha then holding the
national dialogue and going to uh
elections and there is something that
people are not considering when
discussing you know about the coming
dialogue there we are too much stressing
on the dialogue discussion with the
rebel groups but at the same time uh
there is something very important there
are a lot of dynamics in the country
actually that also needed to be
addressed and those dynamics are linked
to uh inter-criminal conflict uh to
corruption and to a lot of other
problems and so if all this is not uh
solved then uh there will be still
questions uh about the inclusiveness of
that dialogue you know uh having peace
with uh rebel groups it's something but
then having social peace within the
country uh to meet with the political
stakeholders civil society etc is also
something that is very important but
that actually is unforeseen by most of
the actors discussing you know about the
future of the country
just how crucial is chad's stability for
its neighbors and how concerned are
chad's neighbors at this time because of
what's going on
well chad plays a very very key role in
terms of uh regional security uh given
the fact that if you look at
the issue of you know boko haram for
instance on an ice swap you know the
china army has played a very you know
strategic role in in pushing back and
even strong strangling boko haram in
particular in the in the in the heat of
the of the you know war in mid and 2010s
and even up to up to very recently the
chad and army was very very uh was very
very pivotal in crushing boko haram you
would even say one of one of the most
important things
people used to look forward to was
the the presence of uh former president
debbie actually going you know going to
the war front uh really faced the combat
group the combatants from boko haram so
uh chad not only serves that's a very
important military role
but also uh it's a good logistics hub
for
international uh security partners for
for all of the countries you know chad
mini also a key member of the national
joint task force with nigeria
cameroon uh and and all of that so it
plays a very important role militarily
for the issue of vocal arab and also
even in addressing the uh
you know not the environmental issues
even within
within uh the region so there's
electron-basing commission and of course
the headquarters is in german and they
work together you know in coordinating
coordinating with nigeria cameroon even
niger to see how they can address you
know a food security issues in in the
lecture because of the shrinking of the
lecture that's been going on for decades
now and if there is recognition that if
you if you don't address the issue of
food security farming from market
farmer cattle
crisis you know we will not be able to
solve some of the most
important drivers of the conflict
because it's not just terrorism
terrorism they are they are systemic or
there are even environmental factors to
this uncharted please a very very
important role in all in all of all of
the measures that in original countries
are taking so
if you and even if you see their present
debut debbie's outreach to
regional countries recently was in
nigeria it was nigeria also
last year visiting president buhari and
the issue of cooperation
you know the multilateral national uh
multi-national joint task force greater
coordination so it's it's a very
important country for regional regional
security and that is why leaders and
analysts across the region are watching
very closely what is happening because
we believe if child can gain more
stability a more more political
stability rather than it will become
even even a better position to support
regional security efforts enrique if
chad does continue to slide into
instability what does that mean for
security and for the battle against
insurgency in the horn of africa
well the stability of chad is a key
issue for uh for the entire region not
only as my colleagues said
for the fight against the giadis manboku
around but also uh for the for the rest
of the
of the neighboring country and thinking
about uh
sudan for instance the violence in in
darfur in angelina
are
rising the level of violence rising and
most of the violence are committed by
arabs
militia so uh the conflict may
uh easily uh cross the border in uh into
chad
in uh
uh looking at the southern border border
also the situation with the central
african republic
has been tense in the past year and may
become tense again
especially after the
inclusion of russian mercenaries into
chilean soil last year in may and then
in september so this is also something
that uh the
authorities in germany are monitoring uh
are monitoring closely because uh might
be my b factors the stabilizing the uh
situation in the country and an instable
chad
might contribute to the stabilization of
the region uh on the other way around
because
uh most for instance of the
central african rebels are currently in
chat along the southern border
uh
in the main main same thing for uh for
sudan the eastern border is uh uh might
be the um the safe heaven for uh
sudanese militias
and uh as my colleagues say for uh
forbade so the stability of chad is key
most of the western part are also well
determined in uh maintaining this uh
stability but
of course the
fact that uh
legitimate authorities uh the the
election of legislative authorities in a
reasonable reasonable
period of time is one of the key
condition
there are many transition ongoing in the
region especially in west africa and
missile
so
the italian one is not the only one but
it can for the moment was one of the
model uh one of the references also for
the transition so we will have to see if
this continues to be dedicated
romaji um i know we touched on this
earlier in the conversation but the
amnesty law that was designed to draw
armed groups into the transition process
does that exclude some entities
i think that globally uh the amnesty law
actually is not really excluding um the
biggest group that are concerned because
even the the fact that have been
included in the fight where the
president debbie uh founded uh is not
excluded from the from this amnesty uh
so globally that's it but uh uh and
that's also the principle but how this
amnesty will be played down concretely
on the ground i think that this is also
one of the unsaid reasons for which uh
some of the main rebel groups leaders
are also not very keen uh actually are
stopping the discussions in the door and
then heading to germany for the national
uh dialogue so i think yeah in principle
there is a kind of large amnesty but the
way this amnesty might be played down is
also one of the fears for some of the
the main rebel groups including mainly
uh someone like maddie uh the head of
the fact
the front for change and concord in chat
is demanding amnesty for all of its
fighters is that an issue that can be
resolved
that would be a very very uh difficult
issue
because like i said earlier the in the
government the traditional government
will give amnesty you know to some 296
people as a pre-condition of the talks
so that shows this is ready to do that
but we have to understand that this
particular river group is responsible
you know or at least in part for the
death of former president debbie now his
son is in power
whether or not he is leader of the
country any son who knows the the
circumstances under his father's death
that and has power to do something would
definitely want to exercise that power
so i think it will be very it will be
very very difficult for you know for a
current uh represent debbie to actually
you know grant a full comprehensive or
broad-range amnesty for all of uh all of
a fact because
it's it's a very it's a personal issue
for him as much as it is about the
national you know reconciliation and all
of that so uh maybe he might then use
that as a concept to get extra
concession on the issue of him not being
allowed to run for for the election so
it's all politics but at the same time
it's still personal but because i think
him him as a leader having stepped into
his father's shoes you know uh chad is
only in his best place but he would
argue and even looking at the issue of
attacks and how the country has been
running
it seems business as usual uh but that
to to some extent is issues he's had
some capacity so he would argue that he
has capacity to continue to run the
country and then if if the
if the
front for change and concord is really
insistent on getting comprehensive and
wide amnesty then he might push them to
actually support his position on being
able to be re-elected because like i
said it's a very it's a very personal
issue for him and that might that might
not be you know entirely possible
enrique from talking to you and ovigue
and ramaji this all sounds like an
extremely
complicated process some might say that
perhaps it's irreconcilable i want to
ask you
are there some immediate steps that
could be taken in order for the
groundwork to be laid for reconciliation
among all chadians
well
the transitional minister the
transitional authorities
have done something that
at least
on
at least for what has been seen so far
uh was not that usual in chad until uh
last year opening the political space uh
to opposition leader to civil society
organization what can be uh what has
still to be done is that this political
openness is not not be only on paper or
not only uh
transitional during this difficult
months but will actually change the
political scene in germany and that
uh they really
and that the um current
elite running in the country will
actually
effectively open
the political scene to other parties
supportive political forces it will
radically change the situation in the
next future
and then as mentioned before i think
it's important to keep the
engagement
that were settled at the beginning of
the transition mainly to revise the
constitutional
charter the transitional constitution
and
to
include the eligibility for the current
transition authorities for the upcoming
election
something that can also be done in terms
of
of calming down the emerging
ethnic and inter-communal
tension in different parts of the
of the countries as a michael
said
is
also to include and to make this
dialogue
the most inclusive possible in terms of
community from all around the country so
uh not giving the impression that the
dialogue is again uh something within
the elite of the country and that
in any case the the the situation will
not uh the situation in terms of
uh governing uh the country will not
change but including as much as possible
different communities making them part
of the of the process and actually give
space during the national dialogue for
the discussion about
about land about
different community tension about
governance about corruption and about
all the other problems that are not
being put in standby
during this
transition and during the dialogue
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests ramaji hoynathi oviguego
and enrique pico
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again any time by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
mohammed jim jim the whole team here in
doha bye for now
[Music]